okay hi everyone we are doing a both
language design review about historical
countries
and this has been one of a long series
and I hope we're finally coming to the
end here
so
who wants to start so geofunctions
without a dated wrapper
and then okay let's take a look here so
what is this
so basically now we wanted to summarize
the scenes that are pending for for a
final decision
so I mean if if
843 wait wait here that that's probably
in Illinois right yes that's the state
that existed from that period to that
period but
actually not supported how do I run this
uh sorry I forget to tell you to to
connect to current
oh yeah can I run it in the in the in a
13-3 main branch build
can I run it in the main branch build or
should I be running it in in a prototype
build
I tried yesterday and it worked in 133
but you need to use current okay fine
so can somebody take responsibility for
getting me to switch back the end of
this sure
how do I do this you have to write it
in that in that field yes the word
current like that yes
okay
okay what on Earth does this mean
those are the states that at some point
included probably champagne so the
kingdom of France the pre-napolionic
kingdom of France you know before the
Louisiana Purchase and things at one
point held that area
okay and we don't have any of the
indigenous stuff for the US
but uh but maybe not that
yeah it's very scatter I think
shouldn't we have a default
I mean we're going to get in trouble
with the with the I mean
you know it may not have had borders and
things like that but there should be
information on
I mean we could just call it the
indigenous
I don't know America or something I
don't know what there have been a lot of
attempts to draw different borders and
things over time I don't know what the
status then is but I think it's a hard
problem okay and there's similar
problems you know in lots of other
places fair enough
this looks really goofy
that we say because in this place the
kingdom of France definitely wasn't
there in 843 A.D
forget the Vikings
you know the French should come to what
else could it possibly so that's the
dates not when it was here that's the
full dates of this entity
by the way we've not generally used ad
have we as a specific designator
in the past right we it just gives a
date
in Alpha we do in mathematics language
in general no that's right
also in Alpha we have data style so
that's what maybe we are creating that
because that label is produced in the
alpha side right so I'm not sure it's
the right thing either well I think it's
I mean at least we should not do
negative numbers for BC please no we
absolutely should not that's completely
crazy
uh is is Alan is not here today right
not yet
so that's a question for him about ad
but what are we going to do about the
fact that it just looks really silly to
have that thing saying
you know so in the next section you have
probably what you would prefer as an
answer
you're right that's that was going to be
my connected yeah so that's part of the
question if this is oh
good enough or or because we were
thinking about when only when using the
date that wrapper is that you get a
dated uh attributed entity right
yeah
that's something that we decided before
and before we didn't show these dates in
in the entities but that's something you
asked some time ago about showing the
so that it will be clear for example for
this many kingdoms of France or many
kingdoms of
for this country that have the same name
right yeah well I mean so you're
basically trying to tell me is this
thing that we're seeing here a corner
case up here or is it you know the uh
let's try one where
my knowledge of history is so pathetic
but
um
okay let's try that where I sort of have
something I get what it should say
that's weird
that's nice that's a good result
basically
what do other people want to say about
this that looks to me like a good result
except that I'm a little bit confused by
these multiple
so these are the different incarnations
of very Britain right when it joins
Ireland or north or
by the way let me make a suggestion why
don't we not use ad after like 1200.
just give the date nobody's going to be
confused
that would save us from you know in
terms of
or maybe if they're both a d it can just
say a d would be another example I think
that's going to get confusing because I
think 260 to 274
even even for small dates like that and
it's going to be pretty obvious here by
the time it's the gallic empire
fine so the only case that would use it
is where
something else
yeah well something is PC BC is like the
first one for example the Roman Empire
27 bc2
yeah actually I yeah it's it's okay to
use ad there but I don't think it's
absolutely necessary I think it's I
think it reads better I mean even if you
know yeah fine done so let's remove it
when they're both ad
even before the the 10th century
I would argue yes
I would go I would slightly prefer to
leave it when it's when it's earlier and
by the way your dashes are the wrong
kind of Dash
can we figure that out please sure
um
I this is something again let's put it
on the list for Alan we're going to use
it I I have a slight preference to use a
d for before
before a thousand A.D but I've not
okay now that I'm looking I think in
Alpha we are using that before the 15th
century
okay all right okay fine well maybe we
thought about it that maybe we should do
the same thing here
okay I just it looks stupid for the
recent stuff like 1922 to 2023
um do we really want to say to 2023 or
do we want to say to present
maybe to present just because if it
doesn't get updated it'll it'll look
strange yes
fine
let's say to present does that make
sense to people
yes yep
okay
this is a good result
that's a very nice result this is a
funky result
the same yeah I mean yeah it's a corner
case so people will have to will scratch
their heads and wonder why it is like
that and that's the way it is
um
what happens if I try let me just try
one here that has again different
historical kind of pattern
oh lovely
I don't know what that is but I you guys
presumably know but I mean this looks
lovely to me these are the pink and
that looks great great result now but
between 900 and 1400 it's just blank
right yeah not make your civilization
okay fine that's fine but I mean that's
fine but we think that's a reasonable
um
by the way am I saving this somewhere
uh do we have a note thing first or yeah
historical data yeah
that looks fantastic
those are great results
okay
all right so what else do we have to
figure out so I think you started on one
that's a particularly ugly Corner case
live stream suggesting that the AD and
BC will be written and smaller font from
the date that is a good suggestion
I don't see any reason not to do that
make sense to people
yeah not natural
we'll talk about that maybe with Tony
about this styling of that
that's a good suggestion
there is probably also the question of
whether it should be ad or CE
that's what I want Alan to opine on
we're not going to use CE
the almost certainly okay we are not
using that yet in Alpha of course I mean
we made a decision yes yes to not do
that
he's accepted as a simple of course but
yeah yeah right right
um
okay
so now
what are these things so this is
what is this
what does that mean
uh when using you identify with a
an entity that have a date like a
military conflict
it only it will search the
historical country that intersects both
in time and space that was what we
concluded but you concluded in the last
meeting
instead of resolving to just the Geo
position it effectively resolves to a
dated geoposition is that okay yes
that's correct that's right so if I were
to say here if I were to say this yeah
position dated of London
uh
you know 1600 for example
what the heck
and it's to be a date object I think
well that's wrong they dated the second
argument of dated
does not need to be a date object it can
be an integer
this is a bug
okay maybe try making a date object just
to see what the bug is
okay it's just a bug
but that's a good result
right everybody agree
yeah yes is there actually given that
we're going to have this is the way it
resolves certain entities is there a
property
for for things like the Battle of Zama
that would be like the dated position or
something
that's a good suggestion
uh currently no so let's do it
let's call it
what should we call it we could call it
um
uh
I mean well one one fear would be that I
mean every property of it could be dated
right
but when you say dated position
and then because like here
we say position there it'll say that and
now what we hopefully will get
is
if we say
um and we say date
oh for God's sake what is the what is
the right term what is the right thing
why I start date or end date or
something
okay so now if I say geo-identify
dated of I'm just checking that this
works I assume it will work
your quotes are
I didn't know the Battle of Waterloo was
on Sunday
who knew
great
that worked
um so so this data Position will return
a dated wrapper with the geoposition and
the date or a date interval in case it's
more than one date right exactly so
we'll return this object
okay yeah it could be a date interval
right because absolutely that can be a
date interval absolutely
and I assume that your identifier works
with data intervals right
yes we are supporting that yes
okay so I mean if I say something like
well here I won't even try it I assume
it'll work
okay
all right now let's just talk about this
case here
so this case and the previous one is in
case you only fit uh input the your
position
you identify the Battle of sama position
you get this result but also we have
this year variant of Union that it's
equivalent to get any any polygon of the
historical countries that intersects
with the position of Battle of Sam
that's a very obscure name
which is what we figured out last time
to do this
yes we changed that uh to Union there
but of course we can no wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait so
and we decided to use Geo variant for
this as opposed to
using for this the other thing I could
imagine doing here would be to say
historical country here
and then to say something like uh dated
of this comma all
see what I'm saying
in other words to have dated people like
one of our rappers that inserts its own
content
from the outside the only reason that's
that makes sense so you are thinking
that all will override the fact that
battle of Sam is exactly
but we are using all in a different
ways argument yes if you look at this
next section this all means to search in
all the time of the entities so maybe
that could be confusing
I'm supporting this more than I'm
supporting this this is really obscure
to me
Christopher do you have a comment on
this one
no I I don't really know
I mean
do you understand what it does
yeah I think so it's basically saying
find all the historical countries but
where right each historical country is
you know the full
time prism thing right extended
infinitely in time is that right yeah
that's what right but I don't know why
it's called Union
we talked about a lot last time I think
right because maybe it's clear that the
previous one to this Union that is
basically take the position of Battle of
Salman and search for any historical
country that is I know I know that's
what it's doing but why is it called
Union
well I think it's supposed to be the
union of all of that that's right it's
there are many different polygons for
for example the Roman Republic over time
uh and and so you want to find right you
want the polygon that represents the
union of all of the the Roman Republic
polygons which is different than for
example the largest extent polygon or
something like that right but this
you're doing two things here you're
doing that the union polygon and then
you're unioning over time no but you're
not because the point the point is is
that basically the union polygon is a
non-foral polygon right and so it's
assumed to be extending infinitely in
time okay I think it's a terrible name
for this
wait here here's the content this is
where we came up with this name is what
if you say essentially
um
right if you want to say Geo uh Geo
variant of Roman Republic uh you know
comma Union
you know get me the polygon that's
supposed to give you the union polygon
right
as opposed to if you say largest extent
or something like that
this is just a logical consequence of of
that working
yeah we have different geography I
understand what that's doing it's a it's
a Time independent polygon
I'm just saying think about it in the
other context in the context of of you
just want to get the maximum extent
polygon or the union polygon or the you
know polygon at this particular date
then Union is a fine word to refer to
the
Union of all the places it's ever
right I just think it's very very
confusing in that geo-identify case
why did it say that why did it say this
why did it say that
sure work
well in general you have to say polygon
of Roman Republic don't you
but maybe I need to say journalist plot
no
it just didn't work
okay so that should work
do we agree
yes it should work
yes okay all right so that's a bug
but let's look back at that geovariant
thing here
retrieving this
you see I would argue
that the return value here should be a
list of geovariants
do you see what I'm saying
right so that to be consistent
yes yes
that's something that we talked
never agree on that fully because we had
this of the full map area and
principalaria Etc no I know but the
return value here I think would be much
less confusing
um
whatever it is just a few of them just
to show what we're talking about see
what it would look like
I mean we could we could print it
differently
I really think it should say that it
should look like that
because that's the consistent thing to
do because then if you say make a plot
of this you're going to get the right
result as opposed to getting completely
Bonkers results
and we will do that also for the other
gear variants right
Etc yes
so now
um
I mean we could consider a different
format here where it's a subscript Union
or something like that we should
consider that
am I making sense
just think through the formatting of
your volume yeah just for the poisoning
now the question is so this makes more
sense to me we're saying show me
identify
a
geovariant historical a union geovariant
historic country
relevant to this that makes more sense
Christopher any comments on this
not really
okay
the
does it seem silly to you
so you into the the way you have it I'm
sorry I'm confused do you mean the way
of it threaded over the I want to make
sure what's that for the output
okay I'm gonna assume this makes sense
let's move on okay because we are
already doing that for for dated for
example the return dated us
right
Okay so
you know this calendar thing looks
really pretty stupid here
I have to say with years I have to
believe that we'd be better
you know the date interval could display
more sensibly here
in any case Okay so let's understand
what this is what does this mean
oh that's dated
Royal history yes
right so all wait let me see if I
remember this right oh wait no that's
not the geography well okay
does that represent the countries as
their kind of the
you know the space-time blob if you know
what I mean this is the space-time blob
and selecting one of these slides
now what happens if one of these
countries intersected here for a certain
time but not for other times then that
will be reflected in the state and
divorce that correct
yes
so for example if we
I don't even know what well in the U.S
for example let's try this right so this
is essentially representing the
intersection between the various
space-time blobs and uh an infinite line
representing here
but thank God I think so yes yes
so if I say
this and then I say
uh
Denver
actually a good one you should try that
but you should try London because it'll
be nice because the it'll it'll leave
the Roman Empire but then it'll come
back
okay
that's pretty nice
is it right
I think it's probably right let's try
London we should be paying attention to
these examples because we're making up
some reasonable examples here one thing
it's a little strangers because I don't
know how to how to avoid it is the data
interval for the US for that last one is
higher granularity because it's trying
to get to today
for the present and yes they can travel
doesn't support uh
different granularity between the start
and and right I I don't know what the
solution would be I it just seems
slightly strange
a symbol like today as ending
well maybe we need that I mean that's a
Jose thing maybe maybe we need a present
[Music]
okay so wait a minute this goes
all right they do
I don't know
actually I think it's missing I think
it's actually missing the second branch
of the Roman Empire yeah but there's
something else that's more seriously
wrong
this here says beginning 52
BC and it's not saying BC and it should
here that's a that's another update
that's a d sorry that's a d
you're supposed to be British
I understand so this is
London
Roman Empire until 52 A.D that seems
very implausible
I think that's about right I think it's
right under uh audience I think we'll
close you
mean I didn't I didn't know that that
the Romans only only dealt with Julius
Caesar was was hanging around there and
like the you know 40s BC but then he
left
but but the the there is a bug here
though which is I think that this is the
first this data to build there for the
Roman Empire is the first date it was
part of the Roman Empire and the last
state but it's missing the fact that
when the gallic empire was broke off it
was yeah yes you're correct
so that can be expressed
okay so then it would say Roman Empire
and then a disjoint date interval here
and then the gallic Empire here
yes that will be the right answer
exactly
okay
I really do think there's a formatting
here that that could be improved with
the date interval for and maybe we need
a different format for date intervals
I mean this beginning and through just
seems very ponderous
it might have been nice to show like uh
you know at least in some cases the dash
like we do the entities above but it is
actually nice like in several of these
the way that you can kind of compare the
dates above and below especially if they
line up
yeah
I think we just need to look at the I
mean I I just think this little calendar
thing is kind of like especially as it's
offset from the plus sign and things
it's kind of like it's cute but do we
really need it
probably not it it it was inherited from
data object which had it in the past and
we removed it from that object but let
me remove it here
and and through is there because there
was a discussion of whether the last
date was included or not
and and according to Nick through
indicates that it is included oh yeah no
that's right but but I mean I'm not sure
that that
but these things
if we just have a dash
but this kind of stuff it's it's
sensible
I don't understand a lot of this I don't
understand this that well the lack of
the disjoint things
what is that by the way
my total lack of British history
knowledge what is that is that like
Wales took over England or something
well not a thousand
Crystal you don't know what that thing
is summer Anglo-Saxon group
or no it's 1200.
Irish
oh who knows
um
hopefully it's correct Okay so
again this is
I don't understand this notation here
this is a way of forcing this thing to
have date intervals
and that's sort of consistent with what
we're doing here forcing it to show its
geovariant
yes
so for data because that's a new thing
we
we talk at that a bit less time that in
the first argument that would mean that
we will show the that in the output
okay so let's just check some
consistency here if I do this and I say
dated Denver
uh
um
I'm going to put in a data object here
even though I shouldn't need to
horrible granularity but correct result
technology is absolutely horrible
right we agree yes yes that's showing
her the same granularity as the input
yeah
okay but the result is sensible here
yes yes
okay let's keep going here
yeah okay that's they have this case
there
what happens if I say
no
uh for now the only uh domains with
historical information are historical
country and Military conflict
but we do know for buildings we know
when they were built
not for many that's why we haven't added
them yet to the historical
okay but but but Alan certainly knows is
did Alan join us yet
actually what which
go ahead well I was just gonna ask do we
have a decision because I remember last
time there was some questions about
whether we care about the start date or
the end date
well what
well for things like buildings would be
a hard one for military conflicts I
guess it's you do it the start and end
date of the military conflict but for
for the buildings I think we had to
begin construction and end construction
date
I don't think we should do I think we
should do when the building exists
because we have a destruction date for
buildings as well so by the way in a few
cases but destruction what's that
it's the same so in that case it would
be construction finished to destruction
date I think it should be construction
started to destruction date
okay
this is perhaps related to the duration
project
yes
synchronizing the fact that duration on
entities gives
um yes but I think there are plenty of
other entities where
um
I mean what other entities there we've
we've inventory this before for example
for the duration project what things
have that
what happens if I do this I'm just going
to watch through there's a bug
why is that saying column
the hell is that what is that
I think Landing site is trying to
produce a map
that's crazy
it shouldn't be doing that
it shouldn't be doing that it's just
wrong that's a bug
to another bug
okay
but that
splatteru
what should we do in this case I mean
this is the bug what it's doing right
now but
I'm not making sense I mean that's a
valid Geo position right
uh right but anyway you identify doesn't
support Moon as data I know I realize
that I'm asking
discouraging some internal error message
yeah well okay Christopher anybody else
what should it do what is the historical
country that is the moon I think it
should just return empty list
there's no historical country that
contains that position fine let's do it
that way no reason to give an error
message now let me try the next obvious
thing
multiple things to try here
isn't that a naval battle it is I don't
know how close to the coast it was good
that was that's a good answer
right for for the moon I'm not sure yet
if
it's fine to to say that it's empty at
least I think you should be empty it is
not a country
some other gear functions will emit
messages sometimes of the form
incompatible
deer models
or bodies
but there's nothing particularly
incompatible about it right I mean it's
just you just want to say
like I mean right you could imagine that
there could be a country on the moon
right exactly just hasn't been set up
that way yet by the way why did when I
said South Pole why did it come back
with Antarctica
did you see that I said South Pole
that's just wrong
South Pole is a continent that's just
crazy
well anyway that's a separate bug
right Jose Etc
yes that's about linguistics
right
but
um and what about
um exclusive economic zones and so on do
we have that data now
we are working on them
I I actually today they started adding
that to to current but it's not yet the
play
okay but so we're we're ignoring
the E disease for purposes of historical
countries is that true yeah foreign
okay fine but even if we did we don't
consider that the country anyway
no not really well actually if we do a
Geo identifier for a country
are we going to have a Geo bear okay
what is the correct thing to do you have
something five miles off the coast of
wherever
the U.S let's say
we have discussed a lot of times having
Maritime borders some sort of another
geovaliant
yeah that sounds like the right thing to
do and that that could be also is we are
still discussing if that should be the
default for for the identify so at least
yeah that's not obvious to me I I think
probably not I think it's confusing I
don't know if Christopher has an opinion
about this if it's in the ocean it's not
part of the country unless you ask for
your variant that includes Maritime
borders yeah I think that makes sense
in my opinion we should use the marathon
borders because people I mean it has
been reported that people ask for a
point in the
Hudson Bay and we say it's not in the US
and also because the maritime borders
are going to be much simpler polygons so
doing computations with them will be
faster
well but then well I guess the only
thing about that I mean that's that's
fair but that one concern might be that
the uh
it might be a little strange if we use
one polygon to be the default that you
granted the Geographics uses and a
different one for like geodentify
nothing else I can imagine people being
used because they they make a graphic of
the polygon and they say hey that point
clearly isn't in this polygon why is
geo-identified disagreeing
I think it's a separate thing let's wait
until we've got the economic zone data
then we have to figure this out
so
what can we do is there's some graphic
that we can make so if I took these and
I said if I took
okay so if I take this I want to see
what it does
I take this
and I say after it produced that I say
Geographics
or journalist plot
what am I going to get am I going to get
a bunch of overlapping things with two
nazira and things like that
some of these are recent extensions so
I'm not sure the fold your framework is
is prepared to support it
what is it taking forever here
well this is for the specific interval
date intervals
okay
so it doesn't show a progress indicator
or anything
by the way why is the Dynasty in
lowercase D and the caliphate a Capital
C
anybody is that just a mistake uh yes
that's from creation that was a
discussion we had with Alan
and
now look it's not consistent that's
dynasties with a capital D that one is
with the lowercase D so something is
wrong
does that make sense
looks looks just like a mistake
okay why is this just literally not
coming back and not showing any progress
Marta
but let's keep going that's the rest of
the discussion see what we are
I do think it would be good this is a
bit off topic but I think we'll be going
if Geo let's plot had some sort of
performance goal or something maybe it
already does and I just don't know about
it
that would be nice it doesn't often much
slower like if you're doing a bunch of
points it's often I think slower than
you know geographics of point for
instance
what is it doing here what the heck is
it doing here I think it's doing an
entity value called per
object and probably it's wrong
yeah it yeah
it's a slow I I would avoid it
I want to just do then let me just do
GLS plot take percent 27 comma
four or something
come on I must have downloaded those by
now
but I'm not sure it's downloading
anything
what's it doing
these these data with data intervals Etc
are very recent objects
so I don't think the Geo from work is is
prepared to okay so this is a bug so it
needs to be fixed okay
um
I'm just trying to understand what what
I mean this is a very cool result but
how do we visualize it okay so it just
had no idea what to do
so what about if I say timeline plot of
this
for example if I say timeline plot a
bunch of Geo things
of of that yeah okay sure
then it will work
okay
timeline part of percent 27 what's that
does it work to say timeline plot of
percent 27 I'm not sure exactly what
that would do but maybe it would you
know no the answer is no it could it
could label them yeah
I mean that's sort of interesting not
completely convincing but but um don't
we have a wave like if you give Talent
part in association or something it will
um yes nice labels presumably dated kind
of has similar semantics to an
association like that this should work
in my view
does that make sense
why why how that will work
well we'll just assume that the date
interval is uniform
is for I entity or uh
volume or something so it's missing
there no the statement of a list of data
intervals geo-histogram
oh I didn't mean that I mean date
histogram I'm
totally wrong
oh
oh that's really cool that works does
that actually take into like it actually
knows about the fact that there's
continuity in the intervals or something
it's not just turning them into their
start date or something
I don't know I don't know
wait the fact that is suspicious
look these this labeling is stupid
and the fact that it goes to 2058 is
unconvincing Could you actually do for
the for the um the
um granularity if you set it to like 10
years or something
your date histogram
I'm not sure you need to put in a list
like that but okay
this is going to give a very light but
but also please that the access is
completely crazy here
for for me over Zoom your window just
went black
yes or
same
one
something is frozen here
oh no
I hope that's not the new crazy
annotation of of okay this needs to be
reported right away to Brett
it's very dead
it's very very dead
am I still
can you still hear me well just several
several what you eat here you've had
several windows on your computer just
turned black
how can you see more than one window
or like the window and then also there's
something at the top that went black and
my gosh I think that's there's some
controls
ah yes this is really dead I I can't
move around in this window I can't get
to the I mean my computer is basically
crashed here
can you not command uh option Escape
oh no no it came back just came back
oops now when I unshared it came back
hmm
um
I know I know I know I'm trying to abort
oh no oh gosh
okay this needs to be reported
immediately because this I think is is
exactly what I was afraid of with the
new stuff with 13 3
the new annotation stuff for 13 3 is
making this go crazy
am I making sense who can report that
I can take over that
it needs to be done within the next hour
right yeah okay could Brett get make
sure they have this notebook
Etc et cetera et cetera sure
I shouldn't need that amount well
whatever dated we should just be able to
give a list 1700 1800 within dated right
to specify an interval that makes sense
not sure because that could be confusing
with it they at least
but
doesn't dated have I'm saying dated
right dated a thing comma
1700 1800 why is that a date list
take a date list
data doesn't take date lists okay
maybe this is already supportive and
dated I don't remember
I don't think of this
but I think it should be
uh the thing is with that uh format
if you put for instance like zero I
don't know three and year five
it would be confusing if it's referring
to no it would just read what date that
what dated says it does not support that
oh okay it doesn't support that that's
why I suggested it
it does for date object but it doesn't
for dated
so this should be able to work
okay geofunctions using data data what
I see that that's fine that's what we
are having a rating before yes
right but that's not what should be
necessary
that's nice
right that's using a low granularity
date object right
correct
okay so there's some formatting stuff
for data interval
there's some details here there's some
bugs but otherwise this is looking great
and I am thinking you know in terms of
when you get an output like this
what can you really do with it
did you understand what I'm asking you
know are there visualizations for the
computations what should you be doing
with it
like for example do we have a notion of
capital cities
for an Empire and so on do we have that
information
I I don't think so so you mean the
capital cities of uh historical country
yeah the history of Capital Cities right
yeah
might be an interesting it's always well
defined okay
I don't think that's always well defined
it's not always well defined but I don't
know what else we might
I mean I just I'm just wondering what do
you do with this list it's a very nice
list but what do you do with it
okay let's wrap this meeting up then
um but so in terms of what we want to
see uh going forward
um
we will need to see this one more time
but probably in some as part of some
other meeting because but there's not
much more there's some formatting stuff
and Bug fixing and so on but this is
looking great
nothing else we want to discuss here
Jose anything else
no no I was thinking of of how to
support all this
entities with data and the ovariant of
Union in Geographics but we can do
something and then okay fine and then
let's figure out the inventory of things
with with dates and positions
great did Alan show up or not
no he didn't okay all right see you guys
very nice stuff it's great to see this
finally work
okay
bye